like that do you notice the difference
in the New York energy versus the LA
energy um it's hard for me to judge
having only been out here for a month
like not really know the people I know
on both coasts are just really eager to
work and like that's today I went to an
shop my buddy's web series because he
decided last week he wanted to make it
put up a Kickstarter and raise the money
and we shot today you know like so I see
that drive on both coasts that's what
that's why I'm deciding which city I
really want to live in I see what you're
saying like people on either one they're
they're ready to do stuff and then
there's whatever there's people that
aren't it's just more you're looking for
people that have that same Drive yeah
like you're ready to go
wherever you are even if you're in
Greenland you know right yeah yeah so I
mean I mean there's there's the clear
differences of the coasts but as far as
the industry the people I know on both
coasts there seems relatively the same
there are small industry standard things
I've noticed like resume formatting is
DIF like they like things differently
here than they like in New York I just
got a worksheet from my manager on that
that it was like here's an L a resume
here's a New York resume and they were
just strange little subtle differences
like font styles or what more so like
the order of stuff on the resume if you
have like what was it like vocal range
sure if you're a singer should always be
on your resume in New York out here not
as much I know like we had TV and film
together with names of characters and
then if it was a lead or supporting out
here they were like split up film and TV
and just put if it's what size the role
is so just subtle little things like
that no I I haven't noticed any big
differences the auditions have been
pretty I it felt like I could have been
in a New York casting office
the auditions I've had out here
you